Hallo Wolfgang. Hallo Stefan. Wir sitzen nicht vorm Salon, sondern?
Wir sitzen in der Garderobe. In der Garderobe.
Gleich beginnt der Live-Salon, der Saal ist gefüllt, es ist ziemlich heiß hier in Frankfurt.
Aber wir haben uns gedacht, wir konzentrieren uns auf amüsante Themen,
oder? Ich glaube schon, sie sind so ein bisschen politisch aufgeladen, ameine.
Aber ich glaube, man kriegt sie heute nochmal sanft als Kickstarter rein,
bevor wir die dann in den folgenden Monaten immer mal wieder aufgreifen.
Eine Ankauffolge sozusagen. Du hast dann eine ganz eigene Theorie zur FDP,
die du uns vorstellen willst und beziehst dich auf einen Film von 1940,
den ich nicht kannte und den ich jetzt aber in Vorbereitung heute Morgen noch
mir angesehen habe. Genau, wir werden gleich mal überprüfen.
Gaslight heißt der Film. Gaslightning ist ein sehr bekanntes Konzept,
abgeleitet aus dem Filmtitel. Ich kann den Film aber auch nicht,
ich hab ihn auch erst gestern Abend gesehen.
Also wir sind sehr gut im Bilde über 83 Jahre alte Filme jetzt.
Und wir werden das mit dem Politischen verknüpfen. Dann müssen wir über,
ja, was sprechen wir dann da eigentlich? Also man sagt nicht Virtual Reality,
zumindest Apple will das nicht sagen. Und man sagt auch nicht AI.
Aber irgendwie hat es doch damit zu tun, also wir sprechen über die Keynote,
wo seit sehr langer Zeit mal wieder gesagt wurde, one more thing.
Und zwar hat da Tim Cook diese Brille vorgestellt.
Durch die man die Wirklichkeit anders sieht und die man ist aber nicht isoliert,
man bleibt verbunden angeblich, wir werden auch sehen, wie das das Kino verändern
könnte, denn auch Disney oder Neuerfindung, ja und Disney ist schon mit im Boot.
Das stimmt, Disney der größte Konzern, sind die beiden größten Konzernen auf
ihrem Gebiet, was Form und Inhalt, Medium und Form angeht.
Ich habe einige Theorien dazu, ich habe auch noch den ein oder anderen Clip,
mal gucken, ob wir den spielen, die Leute sind außer sich.
Ja, ich habe mir Videos angesehen von Leuten, die schon testen durften.
Und alle sprechen von Magie, von Telepathie war die Rede.
Wir werden uns dem mal nähern, ohne so eine Brille gleich aufzusetzen.
Und dann schauen wir mal, wohin es uns treibt.
Vielleicht auch bei all dem Fortschritt wieder zurück in die Reaktion.
Denn du willst dich mit einem Trend beschäftigen, den es schon länger gibt,
der aber immer stärker wird, meines Erachtens.
Also ich habe da zum ersten Mal vor drei, vier Jahren von gehört.
Und inzwischen ist das aber ein Hashtag, der tagtäglich bespielt wird,
also mit Millionen Videos und Beiträgen versehen ist, nämlich ThreatWife.
Genau, ThreatWife ist ein bisschen komisch, dass das so heißt,
weil es geht ja nicht nur um die Wife, also um die Frau.
Aber das Frauenbild steht ja eh zur Diskussion. Also hängt man es auch begrifflich
an der ThreatWife auf. Wir fragen uns heute auch, was ist der Dread Husband,
wie beschreibt er sich selber?
Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema, das wir heute nur.
Mit einem Kick-Off versehen, weil das auf so vielen Dimensionen aufgeladen ist,
während die Protagonisten gleichzeitig mit diesem,
ja, ich zeige ja nur, wie ich lebe, ich verbinde damit ja gar keine Botschaft,
die doch nicht missionieren oder so weiter, also eine der größten Lügen überhaupt,
was bedeutet, dass eine der augenscheinlichst unschuldigsten Phänomene,
dass so eine daherkommt, am Ende dann doch mit die Aufgeladensten sind.
Ja. Bis hin zu der neuen Frage der Religion.
Wir haben uns ja von Anfang angefragt, wer füllt die Lücke, die die Kirche da
reißt und da werden wir heute wieder eine Antwort finden.
Also kommen diese traditionellen Hausfrauen zurück und sind das wirklich traditionelle
Hausfrauen und sind das nicht eigentlich auch Unternehmerinnen,
die traditionelle Hausfrauen spielen für ein Publikum, das dann Hausfrau bleibt.
Das ist etwas, was wir aufgreifen. Das Religiöse kommt vielleicht noch vor.
Wenn wir Zeit haben, dann blicken wir noch auf den Kirchentag,
Denn ich dachte, vor einem Jahr bin ich aus der Kirche ausgetreten,
aus der evangelischen Kirche.
Und jetzt war Kirchentag in Nürnberg.
Söder war da natürlich und viele, viele weitere.
Vielleicht schaffen wir das heute auch noch, sonst machen wir das in der regulären
Folge. Jetzt müssen wir noch ganz kurz sagen, wie man diese Live-Show nachhören kann.
Das ist möglich über Steady, über Patreon, über Apple.
Man kann es auch über Spotify buchen. Man kommt dann zu Steady und in diesem
Monat ist es besonders, man kann tatsächlich die ersten 30 Tage gratis testen.
Also nicht nur diesen Live-Salon, sondern man hat dann das ganze Archiv zur
Verfügung. Wer also mal reinschnuppern will, kann das auch so tun und hat dann
die Möglichkeit zu schauen, ob es gefällt oder nicht.
Genau diesen Live-Salon kann jeder hören.
Und wir können ja jetzt schon ansagen, was wir als nächstes Buch lesen.
Ja, ich habe gerade den Titel nicht präsent, aber wir werden sprechen über ein
Buch, das jetzt in Deutschland zum ersten Mal Texte von chinesischen intellektuellen
Historikern, Politologen, Aktivisten vereint.
Und zwar fragen wir uns ja mal, was denkt man eigentlich da in China?
Ist das alles so gleichgerichtet?
Nein, es ist schon vielstimmig. Aber was bedeutet dieser neue Nationalismus?
Welche Aufstiegsversprechen sind damit verbunden? Jetzt zeigst du mir gerade
den Titel Chinesisches Denken der Gegenwart, Schlüsseltexte zu Politik und Gesellschaft.
Ein dicker Band. Und wir werden uns damit auseinandersetzen,
um mal zu wissen, was wirklich in China gedacht wird.
Denn wir haben wahnsinnig viel darüber geredet, was wir über China denken oder
andere Autoren wie Kai Strittmatter, Theo Sommer und was weiß ich,
über China gesagt haben.
Aber jetzt lassen wir diese Leute mal selbst zu Wort kommen.
Denn da sind Politikberater drunter, da sind Leute, die direkten Kontakt zu
Xi haben oder die von Xi rezipiert werden.
Und da ist es wirklich sehr gut, dass im CA Beck Verlag jetzt einmal gezeigt
wird, was wird da gedacht.
Genau, wir kommentieren ja gerne Sachbücher. In dem Fall haben wir ein kommentierendes
Sachbuch, denn es ist übersetzt unkommentiert von einem deutschsprachigen,
nehme ich mal an, Daniel Lese und Xi Ming,
einem chinesischen Muttersprachler oder Muttersprachlerin.
Selbst das, wir sind so fernsprachlich, wir wissen nicht mal,
ob das Mann oder Frau ist oder divers.
Also in der Hinsicht, das wird wahnsinnig interessant. Und damit würde ich sagen,
gehen wir mal raus zu den Leuten.
Der Salon ist ja schon, also der Salon jetzt ist ja auch schon veröffentlicht
davor. Also wir haben über Dirk Oschmann gesprochen, über den Osten und wie
der Westen den Osten erfunden hat.
Wer also jetzt das Probeabo macht, kann das natürlich dann auch alles hören.
Und ich würde sagen, es ist kurz vor acht. wir stehen auf und gehen jetzt raus
in die Menge. So machen wir es. Bis später.